good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday August
nineteenth is hereby called
order please be advised
according to this person is
being as also being televised
of matter sector please
call the roll Cooley here
Cunningham Carillo here flora
Grayson here Kamlager-Dove
here Maienschein Mathis
quirk Silva here Ramos
Rivas help sorry sorry
Wicks here we have a quorum
we have a quorum we have a
consent agenda is our motion
on the consent agenda move
I'm a strike at the second
of our lives Wicks Ahmed
sector please call for
Cooley hi Cooley I'm
Cunningham Carillo so I flora
floor I agree Senate race and
I Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove
by Maienschein Mathis Mathis
aye quirk Silva hi first of all
I Ramos side Ramos I
Rivas our reasons I works
sign motion this past